all right let's see if we can fit in one
more caller here before we go to break
what if we check in with I don't know
maybe like the two five two area code if
you'll allow it Pat caller from two five
two if you can hear me tell me what's on
your mind today
hello baby I awesome what's on your mind
today yes oh yeah by the way you better
also drink B styles on race and
intelligence that's really cool thank
you but my question is well I wanna
improve my critical thinking skills yeah
you know I want to be better at that so
do you have any books any tips droppin
in Chris yeah Wow I mean there are just
so many right so I think there if
there's a very short introduction to
critical thinking buy it and start with
that Google critical thinking and read
the wiki article about what critical
thinking is and then start reading
through the citations to that wiki
article check out some of Daniel
Dennett's books there are lots of really
great lectures if you go to Khan Academy
that's Kha and Academy org there's a
whole series of videos like a mini
course on critical thinking there are so
many resources at your fingertips with
the internet anything else Pat you want
to recommend what about Daniel Kahneman
Thinking Fast and Slow oh yes Daniel
Kahneman's book Thinking Fast and Slow
would be a good one to include their
work by Dan Ariely although it tends to
start to get more into behavioral
economics but that's still connected so
lots of resources and this you're asking
exactly the right question how do i
improve my critical thinking skills if
only more people ask that question yeah
you know I'm studying engineering
now I want to be a scientist but I just
want to be better at critical thinking I
want to think for myself you know but
the most important aspect is learning
how to critically evaluate thing well
being aware of the fact that those are
skills that would be useful is already
half the battle like they say 98% is
showing up or something like that don't
know who said
honestly not sure if it makes any sense
but it's something people say and on
that note really appreciate the call
okay I'm sorry what was nice talking to
you as well yes so very much
I tell you Pat the mobile phone will be
the death of the radio show Colin right
because of the disaster that that it is
all right that's it for calls today
thanks we'll take calls again next week
take a break back after this